foreign
we are very excited about our next guest
why because he's a fashion designer he's
a badass his name is telfar Clemens in
the house he's joining us first on CBS
mornings to reveal his latest clothing
collection it's called tell far live
price he's pricing the clothes in a way
that's a lot different than anything we
have ever seen before how does it work
it goes like this the collection is
released at the wholesale price and the
cost Rises every second until it reaches
retail price but whenever an item sells
out it will stay at that price forever
for example the crop hoodie starts at
seventy dollars and can go up to 280
dollars but if it sells out quickly say
it stops at 95 that's how much it will
cost going forward it's so cool I love
this tell far claim is good morning to
you it's so nice to see you good morning
CBS you have always said that you wanted
to disrupt the price industry just
disrupt the fashion industry remember
you telling me that
for your bag your iconic bag Beyonce has
a bag and the person that works at
Chipotle has a bag and everybody should
have to pay the same price yeah yeah you
want your clothes to be affordable yeah
how did you come up with this
um I mean I mean you you know you like
clothes that you know you can afford and
that will come to you and be able to
work for you this system of it's
starting low and then rising up to the
point where it sells out that that's it
I've never heard of that no you know
I've done that basically I want the
people to choose the price and basically
the price will start at the lowest
possible price and then go up to the
wholesale price um retail price which is
what um you know but the way it would
work I think for the customer is that
everybody once they see the price they
should go and get it so that was
basically about we'll stop at that price
yeah so it's like you do you basically
choose the demand you know the customer
is the chooses the demand but why are
you doing it why are you doing it this
way because I want people to be able to
get the clothes and for people for the
clothes to be able to have a life
outside of you know what the average
person can afford or like not it being
too expensive but the it's your stuff is
sold out all the time my wife was on the
website just yesterday and a bunch of
stuff was sold out right resale value
sold out is you know 195 percent yeah
more more than the original price of
your famous bag that you see everywhere
in this country you do but I I'm curious
you know uh sometimes uh there's a
resale issue with tickets for example
are you concerned that people could buy
the bags that and the clothes who don't
actually intend to wear them they just
intend to make a dollar off it
themselves I mean that's up to you if
that's you know what the business is and
that's what you intend to do with that I
don't know that's not your intention but
it's not my intention but hey you know
I'm if that's something that someone
else likes to do cool but I think a lot
of people appreciate what they got yeah
so tell us about what the models are
wearing here uh the collection yeah
yeah it's March 27th yeah the collection
will be available they're wearing
sweatshirts
um crop sweatshirts and these will start
and sweatpants and bottoms um paired
with bags and these will start at the
wholesale price again and they will go
up each second what's going on with the
sweat starting the pan yeah that's a
split sweat so that's a split sweat so
as you can be um you know what's the
wholesale price on that so far what is
it I don't know you guys do you guys
have uh you have written down here yeah
if you know it in the back shout it out
but all this stuff is going to be on the
site and you can see the progression the
sweatshirt is priced from 90 to 360.
okay people sell it out at ninety
dollars it'll say right so as soon as
you start if you start buying it and it
sells that at 90 that's the price that's
the price is going to be forever and the
Green in the middle I like this this is
a a sleeveless hoodie yes sleeveless a
halter hoodie halter hoodie and a skirt
yeah and a skirt um so you see it you
know is that the one that's uh triple
Jersey yeah it's a notice that Jersey is
not a triple Jersey but it's a it's a
jersey and when you see the crop hoodie
over on the other side too oh and I'm
having flashbacks of this
story I got on because telfar believes
and I disagree with you on this it looks
so good on you
anybody can wear that so those jeans
start at because those jeans by the way
are very very popular yeah I think I
think they start at about
two 200 yep yeah so no and those are
part of our everyday denim collection
that also too will be available but I
like pretty that she's wearing is priced
at seventy dollars yes yeah so it's
going to start at 70 and go up to two so
again guys once this thing launches live
you got to go on you gotta buy it
quickly and then that will freeze the
price I love this t-shirt dress I
remember when you said to me you want to
make clothes that both men and women can
wear and it's the same thing yeah so
let's talk about this what you have on
us a maxi t-shirt okay can you stand you
know okay so
[Laughter]
NBA Africa logo were you going to bed or
coming to work yeah so that's 93 to 270
for 270 so basically you choose which
price you want I think like you know if
you'd like to pay the retail price and
you're a big spender then I'm going to
vote for 99 okay okay
you can't even make really classy edgy
cool clothes oh thank you thank you so
much more prices thank you so much thank
you so much thank you tell for our team
tell far for coming today thank you so
far live price launches next Monday
March 27th at noon Eastern and we'll
drop new apparel every week through
April 24th but it'll be better be ready
at 11 58 I was gonna yeah yeah we'll be
right